bueno no hay demasiados productos que se
exporten realmente a ucrania entonces
por ese lado es positivo digamos o sea
ya el informe del vídeo aclara que hay
ciertos países que venían exportando en
forma exitosa hacia rusia y seguramente
se vean afectados por esto y tengan que
redirigir sus exportaciones hacia otros
destinos si es que las sanciones a rusia
los afectan en forma directa
el efecto más significativo que también
está resaltado por varios especialistas
viene por lo de los fertilizantes
tanto del lado ruso como del lado
ucraniano digamos que eso está afectando
los insumos especialmente en la
producción de alimentos y está llevando
al aumento de precios especialmente en
los alimentos y eso lógicamente se está
viendo reflejado en los índices de
inflación que ya se venían incrementando
desde antes de la guerra producto de la
recuperación post pandemia entonces
ambos efectos se están
están afectando se en conjunto y están
llevando a un aumento de la inflación y
han bajo ambos factores están llevando a
varios bancos centrales de la región a
aumentar sus tasas para tratar de
contener el efecto inflacionario tanto
de la recuperación post pandemia como
del efecto de la guerra y usted nos
habla que tanto la recuperación post
pandemia como la guerra están impactando
en la inflación pero concretamente como
lo que está ocurriendo en ucrania y el
conflicto impacta en la inflación en
américa latina'
pero no podría repetir la pregunta claro
porque la guerra impacta en la inflación
en américa latina
si lo que mencionaba recién uno de los
efectos más importantes tiene que ver
con el tema de los fertilizantes o sea
los fertilizantes o sea casi un tercio
digamos de los fertilizantes utilizados
en la región provenían de ucrania y
rusia este y lógicamente con la que da
radios esto eso se ha visto ampliamente
reducido y ha incrementado
sustancialmente los precios de los
fertilizantes y no solamente los precios
sino que además están volviendo súper
escasos entonces los países de la región
están teniendo que adaptarse al aumento
de precios por ejemplo una de las cosas
que se está haciendo en colombia es
reducir los precios de importación de
esos fertilizantes precisamente para
reducir sus costos al productor y muy
brevemente el informe dice que hacia
2024 se recuperaría el crecimiento de la
economía latinoamericana porque
claro con estas medidas que se están
tomando precisamente en los en muchos
bancos centrales que están aumentando
sus tasas de interés de las tasas de
intervención para precisamente mantener
bajo control a la inflación que se está
incrementando lógicamente eso lleva a
una reducción en la tasa de crecimiento
porque básicamente se reduce el
circulante y los préstamos digamos y eso
enfría un poco la economía la meta
lógicamente es tratar de contener esas
presiones inflacionarias
pero claro eso produce con respecto al
mismo tiempo produce que que haya un
aumento de precios y una reducción en la
actividad económica y eso lleva
lógicamente a que recién el crecimiento
que se venía proyectando para 2022 se
vaya a trasladar recién a 2023 ó 24
digamos si se va a ralentizar en la
recuperación